this morning marks five years since the
death of Michael Brown in Ferguson
Missouri
you know the unarmed black teenager was
shot and killed by Officer Darren Wilson
who says Brown attacked him a grand jury
later chose not to indict Wilson and a
new interview Brown's father tells Jeff
Pegues he wants the case reopened Jeff
is in Ferguson where he continues our
series policing in America five years
after Ferguson Jeff what are the
expectations for today
well good morning everywhere you go here
Jericka in Ferguson there were reminders
of that painful period in this town's
history behind me that's where Michael
Brown was shot and killed and you can
see the growing memorial there as they
will honor his memory today and
throughout the weekend I spoke with
Michael Browns father Michael Brown
senior who told me that he's not as
angry as he once was but it is still he
says difficult for him to revisit the
moment that his son was killed the phone
call his grandmother gave to see it uh
totally just shot Mike and he's laying
in the middle of Street I turn to my
wife when I told her police just killed
my son
and from there it just was all moving
real slow how does a parent move on from
something like that
I had to tie my painting to a purpose
what I'm trying to impart myself for the
anniversary you know in the years since
his son's death Michael Brown senior
says he's been trying to honor his son's
memory he started a foundation that
includes a support group for fathers and
children he named it chosen for change
something he says has been lacking from
local law enforcement policing is
changed in your view in those five years
so so so so yeah so you don't think
there's been enough change no I could be
more his most urgent plea a second
chance at justice for his son
you want them to reopen the case I would
like for Wesley bill to be okay Wesley
Bell is the new st. Louis County
prosecutor we met him five years ago
when he first made the leap into
politics after protests in Ferguson as a
community we have to get involved the
next year he was elected to the City
Council and last summer in a historic
upset Bell defeated longtime prosecutor
Bob McCullough to become st. Louis
County's first black prosecutor I'm a
living testament that change has been
implemented in this region Bell says
police still have more work to do but
programs like implicit bias training are
a step in the right direction there are
many communities that have never had
good relationships with officers and so
when an officer pulls someone over they
have to understand that they're dealing
with all types of people and be
sensitive to that you have to make sure
that we get it right and do it the right
way
Ferguson's new police chief Jason
Armstrong comes from a small Georgia
Police Department he's only been on the
job here for about five weeks but he
felt the impact of what happened here in
his previous post that incident was the
catalyst for law enforcement in this
country
myself included even though I wasn't
here in Ferguson that rippled the nation
of Armstrong says he plans to gauge
success of the department's new training
programs through community feedback
this department set up we can help
someone's gone for like two weeks at a
time doing training if I go to five
meetings in one week and people are
telling me that they had the police
officers here we're doing something
wrong with it so we got to be out there
in the community trying to write these
these problems that we have this is
where it's starting right here local
filmmaker Chris Phillips lived in the
same neighborhood where Michael Brown
was killed when people come back and
they ask me have anything changed in
five years I might not I said in fact
they being more antagonistic than they
were beforehand I feel bad for the good
cops that I do know the ones that
respect human life as for Michael Brown
senior he hopes the anniversary of his
son's death will bring the community
together what do you want his legacy to
be just me never forget him the spirit
lives do me all the things that I do is
do the spirit of Leo it is interesting
how someone who was a protester out here
is now being asked to reopen the case
I'm referring of course to Wesley Bell
who is now the st. Louis County
Prosecutor he says that he won't comment
on reopening the case out of respect for
the family he knows how painful that
period was not only for this town but
also for the country tarika Jeff what an
important follow-up thank you I always
think of what my grandmother said in
reference to no matter how you feel
about the situation that's somebody's
child and then they have to come back
yeah and revisit that year after year
but you know something about five years
and marking the progress or you know
lack thereof in some areas I can't
believe it's been five years
and as Jeff points out it's if really
interesting to look development the
Wesley Bell is now cut this is now his
case this inspired him obviously we saw
to get into politics and start moving
forward so yeah